the hero [ __ ] of Entrepreneurship of
like I must grind myself down
I'm a [ __ ] hero working super hard
I'm doing it right and it's such
[ __ ] and it's such a toxic aspect of
all work and I hate it but I definitely
worked 110 hour weeks for like months
ground myself down to the point of deep
misery and there is no quicker way to
hate a thing you love than to work on it
like that right like I really love
coffee I definitely got to the point
where I was like I should quit coffee I
should just I I hate this I hate this I
hate my life I hate working in this I
should just do something else what you
should do is start with enough Capital
that you can hire people to work with
you pay them properly and then work in a
healthy manner it's very satisfying
early doors to pull yourself into a
business it is rewarding it's enjoyable
but you're just burning through yourself
so fast and so I regret not starting
with probably twice as much money hiring
more people out the gate and going home
at five o'clock